this is your reminder that the BBC has
yet to address the consistent
transphobic leanings in its news
coverage and while the team behind
Doctor Who is not connected to this in
any way since this is a BBC owned
property I'm going to keep pointing it
out until the problem gets resolved
links in a pin comment below if you
don't know what I'm talking about I'll
stop saying it when it stops being a
problem happy anniversary
doctor let's talk about when you were at
your
best
[Music]
[Applause]
yes folks today marks the 60th
anniversary of Doctor Who and as the
last few years have done um there has
been a collaboration of sorts between a
number of different creators to um
organize things celebrating the moment
this has been done before with
celebrations specifically of the Ninth
Doctor of the 13th Doctor and this one
is meant to cover the whole thing this
is my pick for one Diamond story
playlist to all the rest will be down in
the description the episode I'm going to
talk about is one that I've praised
before but I want to really narrow the
focus this time I really want to zoom in
on the doctor himself I'm going to talk
about the doctor falls the series finale
from series 10 and the second to last
episode for Peter Capaldi's 12th doctor
my favorite doctor I have a lot of great
things to say about this episode but as
I said I want to narrow the focus so
while there is plenty to praise outside
of what I'm going to be talking about
there is Pearl Mackey's performance as
Bill Potts which is one wonderful and
emotional and cathartic there is some
fantastic sass from Matt Lucas as Nardo
there's a really great dynamic between
John Sim master and Michelle Gomez as
Missy there's really great tension with
the oncoming threat of the Cybermen it's
got a hell of a
cliffhanger but no take all that as a
given I want to focus on the doctor
himself and I want to talk about the
fact that the doctor specifically as
portrayed in this story is my platonic
ideal of the doctor and it's not just
because it's Peter Capal who is my
favorite doctor but this episode
specifically this is where he's been
building you this is where he has been
finding himself up to this point and
this is where he says
plainly perfectly in my view who the
doctor is and who the doctor I feel
always should be no matter whatever else
is going on with personality or shifts
in approach or whatever else happens
with any given generation the heart and
soul of what I love about the doctor and
what I want to see in the character is
in this episode on full display and it's
gorgeous so let's zero in on the doctor
himself I'm not going to go through this
episode beat for beat it's not a plot
synopsis if you haven't rewatched it
lately
I would encourage you to do so but
understand I'm not giving you plot
details I'm going on character Focus
here right at the start we have an
emphasis on the doctor sorting things
out through cunning through minations
through being smarter as he himself
points out you too you should know by
now when you're winning and I'm in the
room you're missing something there's a
few other key moments at the start of
the episode there is his still having
some hope for Missy he's seeing her
being influenced into the worst version
of herself by the Johns Sim Master but
he also sees that glimmer of hope and he
needs to know if there's any reason for
him to actually continue to hold on to
that hope and he wants to you can tell
I'm secretly on your side all along you
silly sausage is that true don't spoil a
moment seriously I need to know is that
true but he's also
realistic he does
Hope usually most ly we'll get to that a
little bit later but he's not blinded by
it he needs to know if there's something
really there but reminding us that that
hope that he has for Missy arguably for
the master in any Incarnation but he
already knows he can't help the John Sim
Incarnation at this point that hope
that's important and then there's what
he says to Bill who has been converted
to a
Cyberman I will fix this look at you're
back again s so let's talk about Bill a
little bit this isn't a character Focus
but this is important this is relevant
to the doctor most of what we see of
Bill in this episode is Bill as
portrayed by Pearl Macky we only see
Bill as the Cyberman occasionally and we
hear her speak as that pretty rarely I
am not upset now there is a practical
and meta reason for why this is the case
you want to make proper of your actor
and you want to give pear Macky a proper
send off so yeah you're going to have
her like this but there's the internal
minations of this is how she sees
herself which they validate with this
whole intro scene with her with the
mirror but it's not just that this is
how she is choosing to see herself this
is how the doctor sees her he never
falters he never treats her any
different than he ever has and it's
interesting to note that when the John
Sim Master comes up to try and belittle
her during that exchange she appears as
the
Cyberman but as soon as he walks away
and the focus is just on Bill and the
doctor again then she's Bill the doctor
sees her as she always has been as they
walk we get this glimpse of the doctor
holding back regeneration energy this is
another thing very key to the doctor he
prioritizes other people's safety over
his own this is not the first
incarnation in which we've seen this in
fact there have been times when this
specific thing has resulted in the
situations that caused the doctor to
regenerate in the first place we've seen
that with 10 we've seen that with five
we've seen that with a number of them
but here it's not being held up as the
key to why he'll regenerate later it's
taken as a given he's actively dying
right
now but but he can't cuz there's work to
do and there's people to
help no time to die too much to do
because he has to help because he's the
doctor and then there's the exchange
between him and Bill where she reminds
him that he said he would fix her did
you say that I did say that yes were you
lying
no are you're
right both of those and answers are so
important because no he wasn't lying he
didn't just say it to Plat her he said
it because he truly believed that he
could do
something but he was also
wrong he didn't lie when he said he
could fix it and he's not going to lie
now when he knows that he
can't this is what any good doctor
should do give their all towards helping
go in assuming that they can help that
they can fix it not treated is Doom and
Gloom but to go in and think I can help
I can fix this but also deal with the
reality when they can't and then the
doctor has this line where this
tears let hope he's always looking for
Hope in others hope to have in others
and hope that others can cling to not
necessarily for himself hold on to that
we'll come back to it and then there is
to me what is the thing I will always
keep coming back to as the core and the
heart and the perfect
encapsulation of who the doctor is and
should be always and I have never heard
it said better than the scene in which
the 12th doctor confronts the Missy and
the John Sim
Master at every stage of this
confrontation there are great amazing
lines that sum up the doctor
it's the best I can do so I'm doing it
you have a problem with that you can't
win I know and and I wish that I could
just play you this scene pretty much
unbroken but it's YouTube and I can't
use clips that long so it's going to be
chopped up and I'm going to have to
interrupt but it's so so good I'm not
trying to win I'm not doing this because
I want to beat someone or because I hate
someone or because because I want to
blame someone he has multiple statements
of purpose there's this this one God
knows it's not because it's easy it's
not even because it works because it
hardly ever does this is not about
winning this is not about defeating
anybody this is about helping in any way
that he can but it's the best I can
do so I'm going to do it and I will
stand here doing it till it kills me
you're going to die too and of course
this I do what I do because it's right
because it's
decent and above all it's kind
that's what he is for all his gruffness
all of his short-tempered all of his
insulting people which is 12th doctor in
particular does a lot he is there to be
kind to offer kindness and help and hope
even when there may not be any to be had
he can still try he can still help some
people live just a little longer hold on
to Hope just a little longer because
that's a
kindness just
that just kind and he can do that and he
can give them that even as he is
actively dying then there's what he says
as he gets ready to deal with the
oncoming threat of the
Cybermen without hope
without
[Music]
witness without
reward you don't do it for a reward you
don't do it so people see you as a good
person you don't even necessarily do it
because you have any hope that it'll
help because as I said the doctor cares
a lot about Hope in other people that
they have it that they hold on to it
that they don't let go of it that he can
help them keep
it but he knows that he has to move
forward without necessarily having hope
for
himself of course he says
that but he does still have some
hopes no
[Music]
stars I hope there' be stars and he does
still fight back for
himself which brings us to the last
thing that I think is very important for
the doctor because all of this just
sounds incredibly
selfless and while it is in my mind
important for the doctor to prioritize
others to help in any way if he can
but the doctor is
not the ultimate altruist he would be
very boring if he
was he does
care about who he is and in this
Incarnation
specifically who he has fought so hard
to become I did an extensive video
previously talking about the character
Arc of this doctor I did it through a
queer reading which is not to say that I
am interpreting this doctor as queer but
his journey speaks to me very much as a
queer person in series 8 he was trying
to figure himself out asking the
question am I good man don't
[Music]
know he spends series 9 thinking he's
figured out who he is and being frankly
too grin to Cavalier and it ends in
tragedy and he spends series 10 finding
the balance finally being who he's
supposed to be who he has fought to be
who he wants to be and he doesn't want
to change I don't want to change
again never again he fought so hard to
get here to be who he
is I can't keep on being somebody else
he's not completely selfless he believes
in the kindness of what he
does but he does care about himself he
cares about what he has fought for about
what he can do and bring and
be and he is afraid to lose that when
the time
[Music]
comes this mix this
blend of being so smart so quick witted
so fast to offer help even when he
doesn't know for certain that he can do
much of anything but he can do something
the tiniest thing to save a few people
for a few
minutes if he can do that he
will but he's
not space
Jesus he's not the ultimate altruist
he's not completely selfless he has
layers he has
ego he's a person for all his
kindness for all of his emphatic caring
about other
people there's also
himself and that gives him the depth the
layers that help make him
her
them whatever
Incarnation so amazing and while I love
most incarnations of the doctor I found
something to like in pretty much all of
them some I like more than others some
of them I love
deeply I don't think there has ever been
a
story that has ever perfectly
encapsulated what is for me the essence
of who the doctor
is and who I always want them to remain
at the heart of however they
are one Diamond story on a diamond
anniversary the doctor
falls that might be the
title but the doctor shines bright in
this
one and I love it
and I hope that I could share with you
some of that love for this episode for
this character for this
show 60 years is a hell of a
run I hope it does not end anytime
soon and I hope you've enjoyed this
check out the other videos in the
playlist as for my own work patreon is
how I'm able to do this as my living
even if you can't help me out that way
like share subscribe you know all this
stuff but what I want you to remember
you are
beautiful you are
valid and you are
loved you are the council I am only
running the meetings and until next time
this
council is
[Music]
adjourned time to thank some patrons and
this time I'm going to say their names
as if I'm greeting them welcoming them
to a party Robin Moore zumin Lula
goddess Salida Tac the thing that goes
going in the anime Ruth goer the goeran
Oliver B solitary pictures rri Bogden
Melinda Walters Jen Auntie Kate 808
Becky Sparks fi likes the poodle Robin
Powell TLO Tracy scrapit angry Casper
Dave Hall Rosalyn Bennett have fun
tonight and thank you for your support I
don't know why I decided to do that this
time but I don't know I'm having
[Music]
fun
oh